[Music]
my name is Tyler Bui osterlich I'm a
developer programs engineer at Google
and I work on go and Google cloud
platform
my goal is essentially to make it as
enjoyable and easy to use go with and on
Google cloud as possible so with that
said I'm gonna today I'm going to be
talking about running and maintaining go
serverless applications and I
specifically put running and maintaining
in the title here because getting
something running and started is only
part of the process you make it
available once you need to keep it
available in fast and usable for your
users so with that said I think kind of
the best way to do this is with a demo
so what I'm going to be doing today is
building a web application it's very
very complicated you may have heard of
it before maybe let me know it's called
hello world alright a couple people and
I'm gonna be starting from scratch today
and I'm using cloud shell here
so cloud shell is a service from Google
Google cloud where we spin up a virtual
machine and then give you a terminal so
if you go to console dockside at
google.com slash cloud shell you come
here as long as you have an account you
get to this page so anything I'm showing
today you can hopefully do yourself and
the first step will be setting a project
so config set project and I created one
for this talk called server list gopher
because that's what we all are and I'm
gonna create a new directory called
hello CD into that I really did create
it it didn't exist before nothing in
here and the first step in any go
project is creating a new go module so
how many people have heard of modules
before awesome tons of people all right
so to create a module you're going to
use go mod in it
example.com / I'm gonna call this hello
and this creates one file
it's called Godot mod in this directory
and right now this is really simple it
has two main lines one is module example
comm / hello this gives us the name of
this module all of the go packages that
we create inside of this module will be
prefixed by this module name and then
the other line says go 1.12 so you can
see here I'm using Goa 1.12 it's the
default for cloud shell and what this
1.12 line in the module file is saying
is this module was built with 1.12
that's the intention so if you're on
something older say 111 optimistically
try to compile with this if it works
awesome if it doesn't well because you
need 1.12
so it's kind of this forward-looking
idea of hopefully in the future as we
add more things to go we can support
modules back and forth with that said
let's actually write some go code so I'm
gonna start by creating a web Handler
and I'm just gonna do this with the
standard library net HTTP package so
whoops package hello we're gonna have
one function called hello and it will
always respond with hello and this is
following the handler funk that's our
goal for this so we need two arguments
for this function one is a response
writer from the HTTP package and the
other is a request no return arguments
and then for every request we're just
gonna respond with F print F respond
with hello world and that's it
and straight off the bat here save get
imported school straight off the bat
here this is an HTTP cloud function and
go cloud functions forgo are just HTTP
handle it runs from the standard library
all of the usual middleware if you have
logging to say dump debug information
about all of your requests or your
responses should just work out of the
box so let's take a look at actually
deploying this so to do that clear we're
going to use the g-cloud command line
tool so g-cloud functions deploy and I'm
gonna give the name of the cloud
function that I want to deploy and you
can also specify an entry point argument
the default for this argument is the
name of the cloud function that you are
deploying in this case I can just leave
it off and then it defaults to hello
which is the function we just wrote and
then we need two other arguments one is
the runtime so I'm going to use go 111
and for Tod functions go 111 just went
generally available at next a couple
days ago and then 1.12 is available in
alpha so if you're interested in that
find me after the show and I can get you
signed up
the other argument we need is what
trigger type do we need for this cloud
function and in this case I'm going to
use HTTP and HTTPS code is going to be
deployed we're copying up or the g-cloud
tool will copy up all of the current
directory which means our current module
send that up to Google servers it'll
build that code make sure it's working
and then make that endpoint URL
available ideally and so in this case
I'm using HTTP but there's one other
type of cloud function that you can
write those are background functions and
background functions respond to events
that happen and in a way you can think
of that is visiting some HTTP URL as an
event that happens but
what I mean in this case is something
like pub/sub so pub/sub is this
distributed message bus where you can
send messages into it on a topic that
you define and then subscribe to it
other places and if you're running on
say compute engine or App Engine or
somewhere else you might subscribe
manually to that topic with cloud
functions you don't have to do that
you just say attach this cloud function
to this pub sub topic every message that
gets published here trigger this cloud
function so that's really nice in this
case we have an HTTP function you can
visit it click that link and you get
hello world awesome
and so you can also do things like cloud
storage where let's say a user uploads a
profile picture and you need to process
that picture to say make us thumbnail
that you can display on your application
that's the perfect you space use case
for cloud functions because you send
that into a cloud storage bucket your
function gets triggered process do
whatever image manipulation you need to
do and store it somewhere else but that
doesn't always make the most sense for
your entire application you might have
something that's a directly user facing
maybe it has multiple endpoints that are
all working together and the user
travels between them in that case it
might make more sense to use something
like App Engine and with App Engine you
get an entire HTTP binary that you can
be running so again let's kind of take a
look at what that looks like so we have
our go dot mod file our hello doc out go
file and we're going to create one more
directory called CMD and in CMD we are
going to create a main package main dot
go and this is a really common pattern
in writing go applications where you
create whatever top-level libraries and
packages that you might need to use and
then have a subdirectory for each binary
that you would
so you might have a back-end binary a
front-end binary and so on and that
those would be in command back-end
command front-end and so on in this case
I'm just gonna write one web server so
I'm doing just in the command directory
so in here we have packaged main I'm
gonna write a funk main and this has a
few steps one we're gonna check what
port should we be listening on so the
App Engine runtime will set the port
environment variable to the port that
you should be listening on for your HTTP
server other than that
whatever setup you need to do can all be
dependent on your application however
you prefer to write it but it is helpful
to have a default port in case that
environment variable is not set so for
this I'll do 8080 and then we need to
register our handler so we'll do HTTP
dot handle funk listen on our port use
the default the handler that we just
wrote which is in the hello package and
it was named hello if everything is
working with modules and go in ports
when I saved this file it should just
show up is one of the imports that's
what I was saying before of all of the
packages that we create are just
prefixed by that module path we'll see
that in a sec let's log a message that
says where we're listening to so
listening on localhost and then some
port new line and finally we can start
our server and I'm wrapping this in a
log fatal calls so that when our server
ends if there is some error that
triggered the end of that server we
should print that to the console and not
just forget about it so we do that with
HTTP listen and serve so we need our
port oops
up here
we don't want to listen on a port we
want to listen on some end point which
is we'll say slash hello here really
something I'm support default MUX closed
fatal and there we go so at the top here
we have a few imports from standard
library and we have this example calm
slash hello and that's really it and
this is how you would write an HTTP
server with the standard library maybe
you have some extra routing logics and
things like that but this is just how
you write HTTP servers in go and in my
opinion it's super convenient because
this is an app engine server you can
deploy this almost directly before we do
that it's helpful before you try to
deploy something on a cloud service you
might want to run it locally and in this
case if it's a hello world web server
how can we do that well call go build
let's output this to the current
directory is a binary named hello and
the binary is in the command
subdirectory so that's gonna build a
hello binary so we got this log message
listening on localhost 8080 and I know
what you're thinking you're like Tyler
you're in cloud shell right now that's
in some data center probably in Kansas
or something where's localhost so
there's a convenient I found out about
this as I was prepping this but there's
this web preview up here and you can
specify a port and then you get some
endpoint here and this is pretending
like localhost for you proxied through
cloud shell and if yet it's HTTP up here
the authentication is required so if you
open an incognito window says sign in so
only you as the developer it's just
secure by default can access this really
nice helpful for prototyping if you're
on a Chromebook or working in the cloud
shell in general really helpful alright
so you can close those stop our server
and to deploy on App Engine we need one
more file called an app dot yeah Moe and
we're gonna do App Engine standard here
I'll talk about flexible in a second but
we need a couple lines one is the
runtime again we're going to use go 111
for App Engine there's go 111 and go on
12 just went to beta so if you want to
use that you can in this case I'll stick
with 111 SGA and then we need another
line that says what is the main package
what is the binary that we are going to
be running in that case or in this case
it's in the command subdirectory and
this is helpful for modules because as
you're developing your application your
binary might be a few directories deep
and that's super common and super
helpful and a nice way to design your
application but for App Engine you need
to deploy that entire module so you can
import everything that's needed like we
have our binary importing the hello so
we need this entire module directory so
we say the main command is CMD save and
then we can run g-cloud app deploy and
this is going to go through the same
kind of build process that we went
through for cloud functions where the
current code gets zipped up sent to
cloud storage you can see uploading
three files to cloud storage it builds
on Google servers make sure that the
application works and then deploys it at
your endpoint so you might have come
some custom domain or you can see this
is gonna go at server let's go for dot
appspot.com and so this is using App
Engine standard and specifically App
Engine standard second gen or second
generation and that's built on top of G
visor which gives like sandbox security
to your application so that means any
package that you want to use you can in
first generation runtimes on App Engine
you wanna use specific packages to do
things like HTTP requests so you would
go to
just standard like HTTP default client
get and then you would get some runtime
failure when you deployed your
application saying you can't do that
same thing with context now you can use
whatever context you want you can just
grab the request context directly and
you don't have to worry about it
App Engine flexible is similar to App
Engine standard except you get to one it
has a minimum instance count of one so
it's standard you can go down to zero
Flex you have to have a minimum one that
means you're being charged as it runs if
no one's using it you're still paying
money for it not very nice to use a nice
thing is that you get container images
but I'll talk about container images
after I show you this so let's take this
URL we just deployed it copy we defined
the slash hello endpoint and we get
hello world awesome I'll call out here
we didn't make any changes to the cloud
function that we deployed and that's
kind of the point the code that you're
writing shouldn't be dependent on where
you're deploying it kind of the go code
in one place is the go code in another
but sometimes you need one more level of
granularity higher than say App Engine
or just the binary and so that might be
because you need additional tools that
are right next to your server that your
server might say shell out to or you
define some native code that depends on
the type of machine that's running it
and in those cases you can use a
container and containers can be deployed
in a server this way same kind of
scaling up and down as you need with
cloud run so cloud run announced again a
couple days ago does server list
containers so you say I'm gonna deploy
this container or I'm pushing it and
storing it on Google container registry
and then deploy that and it scales has
needed so let's take a look at what that
looks like
we're gonna need to define our container
in some way and a super common way to do
that or probably most common is with a
docker file so I have one already
written ignore the fact that says buggy
I'll get to that in a sec and take a
look at this docker file so we start on
line 1 here and we say from going as
builder this is the kind of route image
that we're going to be building our
container image in say work in the slash
home directory and I'll call out for go
applications this line 5 and 6 is really
nice this says copy in the go dot mod
and go dot some files and then run
Goemon download and that's helpful
because these are run in different
docker stages and they get cached as
needed so if you're go top mod and
you're go down some files don't change
then you don't have to rerun go mod
download that's really nice when you're
developing because you aren't changing
your dependencies every time you save
and test or deploy so you shouldn't have
to download all of those dependencies
every single time you try to build your
container so that means it might take a
couple minutes the first time because
you have to download everything right
and then you make some modification to
your code and then it's just basically
the compile time plus whatever it takes
for docker to start really nice I
recommend it regardless of where you're
building and running your code do this
if you're running some container line 7
it says copy the rest of it in we
compile our binary and then this is done
as a multi-stage build where the second
stage is done from Alpine and Alpine is
a trimmed-down smaller base image that
doesn't have extra things that aren't
really needed to run a static binary
which you get with go but one thing we
do need is certificates and certificates
are useful for basically if you're doing
anything with SSL or HTTPS you'll want
to include this line finally we copied
our binary make sure it's executable set
that port environment variable that I
defined or talked about earlier
and then the command to start it is
/hello so I deployed this already on
Google container registry and you can
see that at GCR dot io / server list
gopher and this is the project that i
created and you can see i have one image
in here it's called hello world and
there are two versions of this one is
1.0 0.0 and the other is 1.0 0.0 buggy
so like I said I'll get back to buggy in
a second but for right now I'm going to
deploy the 1.0 version and to do that we
are going to use g-cloud again so
g-cloud beta run deploy and then the one
argument we need is image and this is
gonna be exactly what that image I just
showed you was so GC r dot io /
serverless gopher / no period hello
world and then you can also specify your
version the default version is latest in
this case I'm going to do one point open
oh you just talked about so we hit
deploy here and this time we aren't
copying the source from the current
directory it's just going to download
that image from the container registry
I'm gonna I specified US central service
name it defaults to the image name and
we get this deploying container image we
get one option here and allow entik ated
and vacations to service yes that
basically means we don't need to login
to hit this and it's just a little bit
more convenient at least for this demo
and so here it creates a new service
pulls down that image starts it up
performs a health check reroutes traffic
to your new version as needed and as you
can see it literally took a few seconds
let's open this URL just to make sure it
works we're at / hello
and we got hello world very cool and so
kind of from so far we started with HTTP
functions you might have many of these
for your application they might do many
different things you might have some
background functions that are part of
your app but either way you start with
these HTTP handlers maybe you say I need
a little bit more control I want to
bundle this all of this up together I
want to not have these independently
scalable small stateless bits of code
called cloud functions I'm going to
deploy this as a single binary HTTP
server that's running and then if that's
not quite enough or you need like I said
those native binaries or those extra
tools right next to it you might add a
container image around that and deploy
that on cloud run so for a go specific I
found it really helpful to have these
containers to build kind of a go func as
a service with a co-worker so that you
could just bundle in those go tools that
you needed in your container when you're
running on App Engine is go installed I
don't know if you run in a container I
do know because you say in that docker
file yes I need go or I need image magic
image magic is included in App Engine
but you get the point so that's where
I've really liked using it but kind of
looking at the big picture here running
it isn't the end of the story the point
of running something is to do something
awesome with it and you might have all
of these other things around it like
you're using ml at cloud vision building
some chatbot and so on and the point is
not just to have that code running on
App Engine let's do something cool with
it and regardless you kind of have to
maintain that and keep it going
so now that we have something running
let's talk and shift gears into talking
about maintaining and keeping it going
and the first line of defense that I
really see is testing so it's not really
a fun top
it's kind of a boring topic maybe
sometimes but what I want to call out
here is that testing for deploying on
GCF or App Engine or cloud run is just
testing you aren't running something
special that says because I am running
on cloud functions
I need this extra stuff it should just
be a normal go test if you've ever
written go code if you've written go
test before this is what they look like
in this case this is using the HTTP test
package from the standard library and
checks the response code as that is okay
if you do have kind of multiple things
going on and you want to test that all
together you have production I recommend
creating test projects as needed and
your test project can be completely
independent of all of your production
resources and then you don't have to
worry about running out or accidentally
deleting something from production if
it's just a completely separate Google
cloud project the other thing to keep in
mind and this is kind of true for any
microt service application that you're
building is implicit dependencies so I
built one application where users could
go to a website and request translations
of certain text so you get free form
input for what text and then a selector
box for what language should that text
be translated to and so that request
that form post response gets sent to
some server and then I didn't want to
run that translation right there right
then because it might take a little bit
long it might take 100 milliseconds it
might take more
so what I did was I published all of
those two pub/sub and I said here on
this topic go translate this text into
French and then I created a cloud
function that listened on that pub/sub
topic brought things in said okay I'm
going to take that text translate to
French store it in the database and then
the user refreshes and they get the list
of translations from that database
that's awesome
but you kind of have this implicit
dependency there you have one code
that's pushing into pub/sub and this
other code that's pulling
from pub/sub and they have that implicit
dependency that says what is the format
of that data that's going back and forth
if you're calling it directly you're
writing go it just typed checks it
compiles it it you're good but if you're
going through pub/sub if you're
publishing events and so on you you have
to be a lot more careful so I don't have
a hard and fast rule that says what's
the best way to manage this but
documenting it having a good clear
picture of where all of the data of your
application is going will be super
helpful and the other issue is
visibility so it's like yeah sure Tyler
you're running all these containers that
go up and down you have whatever 25
containers here what's inside these
containers 30 ok what's inside these
containers anyone I don't know so you
need that extra visibility to say what's
inside these how are they communicating
back and forth is it fast can I be bug
it and the way to do that or at least
one way is with tracing so tracing
there's a package or a library called
open census and this is instrumented in
multiple languages in this case from
shell and go but the same principles
apply you start by creating spangs
and then you end those spins at some
point in the future in this case I'm
creating a span called example comm
slash hello dot hello and the convention
for creating these is you take your
package name dot the function name that
way later if you need ever need to debug
and find the code that's creating this
bin you know exactly where to go and
then this calls defer span end and defer
means this end call will run when the
function returns or at the end of the
function and then when you get from this
is it returns a context and as you pass
that context around through your
application you get to see these other
spans that are created and as you create
a new span from this context it all gets
attributed to the parent
or top-level span that created this so
we'll see an example of what this looks
like in a little bit once you do that
you have to export that data somewhere
so like I said open census is open
source multiple languages one benefit of
that is that the exporter can be
whatever you want it to be so that might
be stackdriver
which I have an example of here
stackdriver is Google clouds application
performance monitoring suite but it
might be data dog or it might be some
local just print it to standard out as
I'm developing and that makes it really
easy to recommend the tracing throughout
your entire code because if you ever
want to change where you're exporting
that data later it doesn't matter it's a
small maybe ten line configuration
change that says export this somewhere
else the other side of kind of the same
coin is tracing you have to explicitly
add or maybe there are plugins to help
you for example there is a open census
HTTP plugin so you just say trace all of
these handlers and it just works the
other side of that coin without having
to do much manual work is profiling and
profiling gives you say CPU or heap
usage of your code by calling this start
call so what's this look like again
let's do a demo you may have guessed
already but let's deploy that buggy
version that I talked about earlier so
we look here we have 1.0 and 1.0 0.0
buggy let's deploy this on cloud run and
for this version I made a few changes
one or two of them are I added tracing
and I added profiling which I just
talked about and then I also added two
other bugs so my hope is that I can
deploy this throw some traffic at it
just to make sure those bugs get
triggered and then we can go look at the
tracing and profiling tools
the cloud console to hopefully find
those bugs so we'll stick with us
central one the same service name this
will deploy it should take just a couple
seconds here
doing the same thing assigning traffic
to the latest revision and done I'll use
curl just to make sure this is still
working whoops
/hello go delete all of this extra stuff
cool
we're still getting HelloWorld
everything is still working no obvious
bugs at least from this perspective that
one took a little bit longer so one
option we could send a few thousand curl
requests and we could go home at some
time around dinner or there's another
tool called hey and what hey can do is
we can take this clear Hey and dash Z is
going to be how long we run for again
all right and hey was built by a
co-worker of mine JB D and it's written
and go and it can send a configurable
amount of traffic at the URL that you
specify in this case we're going to say
run for two minutes send a bunch of
requests to this endpoint while that's
going over here let's open trace and
I'll call out on this overview page
there are reports of the different
traces that you get so you might get a
distribution of how long that trace took
you can see latency and request
percentiles and then example traces that
correspond to those requests in this
case let's just look at real time
[Music]
responses that are coming in and all
over strict this to example.com slash
hello dot hello which was the span that
we care about
zoom in on recent code and immediately
calling out here we have a bunch of
requests at the bottom those look fine
those look like about zero great we have
another line at about three hundred
milliseconds that's probably not what
we're looking for for a hello world
application so that's something to look
into and then the third group is we have
all of these clustered kind of in the
middle
random latency traces and so just to say
the x-axis on this is the time line and
so as you go more left you get older and
older and then the y-axis is how long it
took in milliseconds and so when we
click one of these dots down here we get
this time line at the bottom which
includes all of our spans so this
request took zero milliseconds I would
say that's an acceptable amount of time
all of these are taking zero and then
you can see we have this one spin of the
hello span and let's look up here at 300
milliseconds so we have our hello spin
and then inside of that there is a slow
span and this is eating up that entire
300 milliseconds so looking at the name
of this we have example.com slash hello
dot slow it's pretty clear where we can
look when we take a look at the source
code that I deployed in a little bit
where we can look and hopefully find out
why this is taking 300 milliseconds all
of these other ones in here
96 milliseconds 95 why you look here
your spins nothing is there nothing's
really helpful nothing's showing up but
it's still taking 95 milliseconds what
what is there to do about that so astute
gopher as you can probably guess we have
profiling
and profiling the default here is CPU
time you also don't want to double-check
so you have hello world and hello world
test as your services check that you're
using the right service or looking at
the right service here I've spent more
time than I care to admit looking at the
wrong one and wondering my profiling
wasn't there just take it from my
experience you can specify what version
you want to look for let's say what time
frame you want to look at and
immediately jumping out here is
Fibonacci and you can probably guess
what this is doing but before I get
there this is called a flame graph and a
flame graph is giving you some metric in
this case it's CPU time but like I said
it could also be say heap allocation
where on the x-axis you have how much of
that metric did this function call take
across the profiles that we've received
on the y-axis you have these stack
depths of the functions that were called
so if we start at the top here we have
some standard library things that
connection dots serve serve handle or
serve HTTP and so on until we get to
hello which was the handler that we
wrote and then right underneath this
we're calling Fibonacci and Fibonacci is
a very wide very deep stack thing and
you can we'll see what the code is for
this in a second but it's not every time
you look at profiling it's going to be
this obvious but it's just another tool
in the box to check of where is the CPU
time going why is this request taking
100 milliseconds look at profiling very
clear so let's take a look at what that
looks like so let's do CD into buggy
this is all the same code that I wrote
before there's no app Gamal here because
since we're just deploying a container
image we don't and not on App Engine we
don't need that app that yellow so you
want to see it right here
all of the other code is the same except
for the changes that I made so let's
take a look at what that looks for we
will tweak that not worry about swap
all right you can see we have extra
imports here of open sense estado
IO and then there's the stackdriver
exporter variable on line 15 and then in
an init function which is run during
package initialization for your go
program I create a new stackdriver
exporter just like I showed you register
that as the trace exporter and then on
line 24 here I want to call this out as
you're developing your application
you're adding tracing you say yeah
export my data to stackdriver you do it
nothing shows up that's because by
default there's sampling that goes into
all of the traces you don't necessarily
need to sample or send traces for every
single request that comes in so you can
sample say 1% or half a percent or 0.1
percent depending on the level of
traffic that you need and the visibility
into all of the requests that you have
when you're debugging you want maximum
visibility you're not concerned about
QPS just show me the traces are they
working in that case you need this line
right here that says always sample
always then that data don't do any 1%
magic or anything there are a bunch of
options that you can look into but I
want to call that one out finally you
can see in our handler we have this
hello span that we created like I said
before open census has HTTP plugins that
will give you even more information and
help you debug your web applications so
I wouldn't do it this way if you're
writing it look into that OC HTTP
package and then you get to the bugs
that I added so it's a switch that
creates a random number that's either 0
1 or 2 if it's a 0 we're gonna call this
slowed function if it's a one we call
Fibonacci so we'll start by looking at
slow and you can see we have a span that
we created hello dot slow right here and
then we call time dot sleep for 300
milliseconds probably not something you
want to do in your production
application but it's immediately obvious
where to look and how to
this may be I don't know we want to
sleep for a hundred milliseconds or just
none all right and then we have
Fibonacci and Fibonacci returns the nth
Fibonacci number and it does nothing
special it's just recursive has no
caching and it's immediately obvious yes
this is something that we could focus on
we can spend our developer time and
engineering effort optimizing this
function and yeah so I think with that
we started with this cloud function we
added a main dot go a package main to
call that function deployed that on App
Engine added a docker file to create a
container image and then deployed that
on cloud run then I showed you a few
tips of adding tracing and profiling and
so tracing is a little bit higher effort
than profiling profiling of a few lines
of code that say enable this tracing you
have to plumb context throughout your
entire application and how many people
have done that or at least tried to you
look at context and oh my god I need to
pass this through my entire application
how and I'm gonna update how so that's
kind of a slow process and if you have a
very big application with a large team
of engineers working on it
one team might not have that as their
priority for a quarter when another does
so it's helpful to have those kind of
two parts of the same side or the same
coin to get different visibility testing
like I said tests should just be tests
your go code should just be go code
hopefully with the caveat of you have
some authentication requirements
depending on where you're deploying and
things like that but the code that
you're writing should always look like
go code without extra surprises just
based on where you're deploying it and
with that said that's all I have for
today your feedback would be greatly
appreciated you can do that in the
app and if you have any questions you
can either find me on Twitter or I'll be
out in the hall after the talk thank you
[Music]